だからただ言いたがっているのは早いよということだけなんですね
だから人々の理解できない速さが行ってるんです
そこでこの一つワンセッツナ
一セッツナはパーリ語でカナと言うんですね
ちょっとアイル語の言葉も覚えていた
これカナと読むんですけど
心も入れて ティッパッカナと言うんですね
心を入れたところで だからシンセッツナ
ですから この一番時間の短い単位はシンセッツナなんですね
これ秒単位で数えられないのは
このインド文化では 我々の国でも古い文化では
1日は60時間なんですね
24時間じゃないんです
1日  1日は60 シックスティアワーズ 60
時間で だから昼間は30時間と夜は30時間に分けてるんです
この1時はまたもう60秒と60分と60秒に分けてるんです
その星占いとか それで計算するんです
20時間ではなくて だからもう大変ややこしいんです
もう今は全部チャートやら全部普通のヨーロッパ型の20時間のシステムになってるでしょうに
古いアルマナックというものはまだ伝統的なものはできてますけど
その場合は計算は全部60時間に計算しているんです
ですから もう例えばもうなんとかなんとか
星がまあ13時30分13秒に現れます
と言っても  13時っていうのは 1時じゃないんです
1時30分ではないんです
だから古い計算でそう言ってるんです
たまにそれ間違ったりすると
全部占いはもうまるっきり間違ってしまう
だからいまだにも自分の国で
この言葉で もう口言葉ではね
まあいろいろ言葉にいろいろランクありますけど
書く言葉と喋る言葉といろいろありますからね
まあ喋る言葉の場合はもう 1日ということを言う場合は
なんか表現みたいに この子は60時間遊びばっかし何もやってないんだと言うんですね
で 60時間っていうのは 1日中 1日中遊んでばっかしって意味なんですね
ですから まあ昔からのそういう決まりです
ですから この 1秒と言ったっても
こういうテキストを書いた時代の 1秒はそういうふうに違うんです
ですから 今の 1秒に昔の 1秒 2
秒半入ってるんですね
古い人々は2.5 秒経過と言ったっても
現代時計では 1秒経過ってなっちゃうんです
まあ今はね いろいろ研究してね
いろんな機械使って研究して計算して
科学知識使ってるし 昔の人々はほとんどこの瞑想中心で知識作ったんだから
いろんな瞑想をやったりとか
ヴィパッサナーではなくてね
もうインド文化っていうのは瞑想文化だからね
で いろんなことを心で直接観察して
それを喋るんですね その時でも当たり外れは当然ありますから
喋る場合はね そういう中からできた知識なんですね
だから医学も同じなんです
人を殺して分解して ああだこうだとかね
いろんな薬飲ませて それで死んだと
じゃあこの薬は毒だとかね
そういう風な研究をやったことはないんです
[笑い]そういうアガスティですか
このアーユルヴェーダの一番偉い仙人がね
神様として拝んだりはするんだけども
ある人々は我々拝めませんだけど
我々にとってはアガスティっていうのはある
仙人っていうのは いわゆる行者で
薬治療法を世の中に紹介した人なんですね
ですから 彼がもう森の中に入っちゃって
まあ一生懸命修行一筋で
で 世の中の体の構造やらね
物質の植物の構造やらね
そういうものを観察して
それから得た知恵で体はこのように働くもので
このように自然やら星やら
こういう関係で体は変化していくんだと
ただ食べ物だけではなくて
星の位置も太陽の位置も月の位置も
地球で自分がどこに生まれたというね
そういうことによって体は変化するんだと
ですから 物質にしたっても
それなりにいろいろ影響を与えていて
で 体のこのバランスが崩れる場合は
まあこういう風に崩れちゃったら
こういうこういう植物でいいんだと
こういう風な場合は こういうこういう植物でいいんだけど
この植物は朝飲みなさいと
この植物は夜飲みなさいと
そういう風に時間まで決めてるんです
だからヨーロッパの治療法と随分もう全く非科学的で
もうこの薬飲んだら熱が冷めますけどというならば
朝飲んでも昼飲んでもいいんだけど
これは夜しか飲んではいかんというんですね
昼は飲むな飲むなとか
で 熱は昼もあるんだからどうしますか？と
くだらないことを言うなと言ったって
まあ昼だったらもう熱冷ましにはこういうこういうことをしなさいと
そんなもんなんです ですから
考え方は違うんですね
微生物があるんだとかね
ミネラルが欠けているんだ
ビタミンがないんだとか
そういう考えはまるっきりないんです
微生物の概念は全くないんです
だからといっていい加減な薬かというと
そうはまるっきりないんです
何の副作用もなく すごい体がもう治りますから
で またそのアーユルヴェーダ的に生き方をするならば
こんな病院要りませんし
病院に入院するまでひどい病気になりませんだから
この最初からもう健康な時からの食べ物の時間やら全部考えて食べてるんだから
野菜だとか言って朝も昼も夜も食べることはしないし
朝食べる野菜と夜食べる野菜ってのはそれちゃんと区別しているし
夜食べない野菜っていうのもちゃんと決まってるし
ニガウリとかはね 僕は覚えてるのそれだけですけど
ニガウリは夜食べないととか
まだたくさんあることはありますけどね
なんかスズムラサキに夜食べないんですね
で かぼちゃはいいみたい
まあそれなりにまあそういう昼の夜のね
まあ区別があったり 体の体質によってね
まあこういうのを食べてはいけない
こういうのを食べてはいけないとかって
ですから まあそれで別に病気になることはないし
入院することもなくなっちゃうし
手術することも必要でなくなっちゃうし
まあそれでそれで まあとにかくその知識っていうのは
このインド文化の知識っていうのは研究
実験結果ではないんですね
いわゆる直視結果なんですね
直感の結果なんですね
直接構想を見て こういうことをやってる
もう繰り返することですからね
ですから インド人はアガスティアはもう神様だと信じているのは別に無理
現代人しかやってませんだけどね
森のないどうせ知識がだらけているんだから
昔はもう仙人と言ったっても
アガスティアさんが書いたテキストをね
チャラカサンヒタという大きなテキスト
それを暗記してもう医者になっただけなんですけど
本当にそんな昔書いたテキストの膨大さっていうのはすごいもんなんです
全ての植物の説明入ってるんだから
そのまま治療にですよ
あれを暗記させちゃうんですよ
子供に いろんな方法で
子供たちも朝から晩までいろいろ遊び
暗記する遊びいろいろありますからね
いろいろなやり方で暗記して
それから先生の前でも毎日毎日毎日それを発表して
発表して もう知らないうちに全部身についているんですね
今もインドではね そういうシステムは伝統的に教えるところはあるんです
だからもう慌ててもう大学にしたって
もう年ではないかと思っていて
じゃあ年間にアーユルヴェーダの勉強しようと思ったって無理かもしれない
年じゃなくて年 年に何やるかってただ暗記するだけで
暗記しなくたってテキストあるんだからいいんじゃないかと
それでできないんで やっぱり暗記した方がいいかもしれませんし
ものすごい関連性のものはさっと出てくるんだからね
それコンピューターでも使ってやれないわけないんだけど
すごい膨大なデータ量ですから
かなりの大型コンピューターでないと
もうこの病気にこの薬のこのシステムだよと出てこないかもしれません
だから単純じゃないですが
単純に書いてあるんです
とにかくそういうふうなことだから
時間についたっても まあにしたのは
あるちゃんと論理あるんです
なぜならば秒は 1 分でしょう
分は 1 時間でしょ 時間は 1 日と
すごい あの もう考えてるんです
なんでっていうのはもう入ったかとさっぱりわからない
日本ではなんかもっと短かったっけ
日本昔は何時間でした？1 日は
時っていうのは時間  という事は時間
1 日 とにかく昔はね どんな国でも時間というシステムはなかったんで
そこは全部余計な話で
で まあ心の瞬間というのは
刹那っていうのは まあこれというふうには言えるものではありません
で でも論理的にはいくらか
1 秒の何分の 1 かということは論理的には言えないわけじゃないんですね
で また問題っていうのは
我々が考えている時間というのは
この移動で言ってるんでしょうね
この天体の移動 ワンサイクルね
もう移動を考えて時間決めてるんですね
物質の変化から時間決めてるわけじゃないんです
だから仏教の時間っていうのは物質の寿命なんですね
天体の移動ではないんです
そちらもちょっと時間論のちょっと時間時間という同じ言葉を使うんだけど
内容は違うんです 例えば 1 日でっていうのは
この地球が 1回転する時間でしょうに
1年っていうのはひと回りする
ですから この宇宙空間である天体がある天体に比べて移動する速さなんですね
時間っていうのは 我々が今使っている時間というのは
で 仏教で考えている時間っていうのは
そういう移動っていうのはもうどうでもいいことであって
別にすごいいい加減なものであって
相対的なものであって
とにかくそれをしやら物質は存在
一時的には存在していて
その存在は変化していくんですね
ですから あるものの そのものとしていられる時間は時間というんですね
いわゆる寿命なんですね
寿命に時間という ですから移動ではなくて変化
だから比べることできますね
この変化するときはどれぐらい天体が移動しましたかと
見て もうその時間に計算して合意に合わせることは別に数学的には可能ですけど
だから移動と変化ですね
とにかく仏教の時間論というのは変化論である
だからそれは実際的な時間論なんですね
移動したっても変化しないんだからね
普通は だから私にもいろんなところに移動することはできますし
どこに移動しなくたって
私はどんどんどんどん年取って変化するし
だから宇宙に宇宙の空間にどこにいるかということは
存在としては全然意味がないものなんです
その宇宙の空間にどこにいても
そのいるものが変わっていくことは一番大事なことなんです
それで 普通の数学では
時間というのはあるものが宇宙空間に移動すること
仏教の時間というのは
そのものがどれぐらい持てるか持てないかということなんですね
いわゆるバッテリーなんかの寿命と同じ
これは一年ですよと言えば
一年間は機能すると それでは終わりというふうなことで時間と取っているんです
で  六十時間といったのはまた同じくこの天体の移動なんです
この心の瞬間の時間 いわゆる一刹那
チッタクナ これはもう存在であり得る一番短い時間単位ですね
すべての存在の中で どんな梵天であろうが
どんな高次元の神様であろうが
心があるんだから 神であるんだから
で その心というものが生滅変化しているんだから
その生滅変化の一番短い距離を
単位をチッタクナと呼ぶんです
ですから この時間単位はもう存在の一番短い
考えられる一番短いものなんです
そのものをまた三等分に分けちゃうんですね
この三等分に分けるべきかないかはわかりませんだけどね
まあこれさえ短くてわからないんだからね
指を鳴らす時間のね 一兆分の1ぐらいだから
一刹那が これは 1兆分の1をまた 3つに分けるんですね
で これ 3つに だからもしかするとこれはもう波という概念当時でなかったんですし
もしかするとこういう波かもしれませんね
で 波という概念は昔はなかったんですね
ですから ここは生ですか
で こっちは住と書いてこうですか
住は 滅はちょっと難しいので書きません
生住滅ですね で  3つに分けちゃうんですね
これ私の縦の線はちょっとまあこれは点線で書いた方がいいかもしれません
で 波の場合はまあこんなもんだから
だから心の波一つ取っちゃうと
これ一刹那なんですね
これ波一つなんですね
きちんと だからちゃんと
これ波のピークですか
と これは波の一番底のところで
そういうのを一応物理学では決まってる言葉ありますけどね
知ってる方は教えてください
上と下は 物理学ではちゃんと決まってることあります
とにかく波だったら一番高いところと一番低いところがあります
ですから 一つの波はユニット取っちゃうと
仏教ではこういう風に取ってるんですね
だからこういうものを繋げればずっと波が存在するんですね
この波をね そこでこの一つの沙羅を見ると
このピークのところで
この心があるとわかっちゃうんですね
ですから そこで生まれるところだと
それから生まれて生まれていて
これで住の最高なところですね
で 住のところからどんどん低くなって消えると
消えたらまた波がどんどんどんどん上へ上へ上へ上へ行かなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそういう風に生住滅を考えてるんです
で ここのこの一番底の長さとこっちの長さ
だいたい波だからイコールなんですね
まあ波の場合は  3等分に分けるんだから
この生まれた瞬間から
まあそこら辺まではほとんどわからないし
ここら辺は一応わかっている状態で
この半分に行っちゃうとまた消えていっちゃうんですね
力としては そういう風に 3等分に分けてます
それほとんどただの頭で論理的に考えて分けているものなんですね
一つの 一つの刹那を生の刹那と住の刹那と滅の刹那と 3つあるんだと
だから生住滅っていうのは
物質は波で流れているんだからなんですし
当時ではそういう物理学はなかったんだから
波という概念はなかったんですね
このこういう概念での無我論に
無我論をね 頭で理解するためには大変必要なものなんです
で 波のことを知っているならば
例えば水の中で 我々はここでちょっと石一つを落として波を作っちゃうと
こちらでも何か実体が池の向こう側から行くんですかと
全然何も行かないんです
ただこちらで水で波を作った
その波が消えると次の水が波を作るだけ
ここから何か実体的な変化しないものがずっといたわけじゃないんです
ですから 実体なしに変化しない
なしに波だけは存在するんですね
それはいろんな科学実験ではいろんなものをそれ作って
例えばこの球をたくさん並んでおいて
一つの球 次の球にぶつなぐっちゃったら
その球が次の球に触れるし
その球は次の球に触れて
またこの波が生まれるでしょうに
だから一番最初の振り子している球が入っていた何か
消滅変化しない実体的なものが次のたまに行って
次のたまに行って 最後になんとかなったということにはならないんですね
ですから この水の波でも
だから水は波はするんだけど
水は動かないんですね
水はただ自分で上へ上がって下におろす
それだけ だからもう 波打つために水が出てくるんだったらね
我々生きていられませんね
海はどれほど波が作っているかというと
あれはただ一箇所で水は上がったり下がったり上がったり下がったりする
ですから 私は昔 川に何回も入っていて
川っていうのは流れるものだからね
結構危険なんです ちょっとしたことでも命がなくなっちゃうぐらい
でもそんなに激しい波がないんです
それですごい驚いたこと
海を見たところでは川と比べたんですね
川であんなわずかな波しかないので
あれほど怖いし 海だったらもうとんでもないものだと
それでいくらか大きくなったところで
みんなに内緒で もうガキの時はもうもう海に入ってみたら
なんのことなく遊んでるんですね
自分が入った時はちょうどよかったんだと
波も波もなく ちょうどよかったと偉そうに考えていたんだけど
外を行ってみたらそうではない
すごい波があるんです
波があるんだけど 水は動かないんだから
自分がなんか安心して遊べたというぐらいのことなんですね
だから波が来て 波と一緒に上へ上がっちゃっても
どうとやらそのままボーンとしてまた落ちるだけでね
なんのことは同じ場所なんですね
川の場合はそうしないんです
どこに流れてどんな石にぶん殴るかわからないんです
だから川ではもう本当にすごい苦労するんだからね
いろんなものに捕まったりとかね
枝はなんかいろいろ木の枝なんか捕まれる
それまた折れたりするし
だから川にもよくなってる枝ほとんどない
我々遊ぶところだったらもう全部折れちゃって
ですからこのまあ波っていうのはすごくいいことで
この何か変化しないものは何か次に行く必要はないんですね
でもじゃあなんで波が生まれるかというと
この前の瞬間でエネルギーがあったんだからなんです
だから ある一定の水が上へ上がっちゃったら
あるエネルギーはそれはドーン落ちて
また下へ行っちゃったら
またあるエネルギーで
それに反対的に隣の水が反対側に行動する
心もだいたいそういうもので
エネルギーですから 波で波だけだって心はないと
まあまあ そういうことなんですが
そこまでは別にまあ分かりやすいんだから言っただけのこと
[咳]心の波の場合は
まあ一応生・住・滅というものはありますけど
一応心として仕事できるのは住の時ということはわかると思いますね
あの 生の時はもうまだまだ出来上がってる時だから
まあそれで精いっぱいで
一旦できちゃったらやることないんだから心としていて
それからどんどん機能は失っていっちゃうんですね
ですから 心として働くのは住の時だけ
この一刹那の中でも生刹那と滅刹那はもう何もしない
住の刹那でなんとか心として自分の機能ができるんです
次にこの物質の寿命なんですね
物質の寿命はこの この心の寿命よりは十七倍にしているんですね
十七倍長いんだと ですから
物質一行が心より十七倍寿命は長い
それもまた生・住・滅に分けてるんですね
生・住・滅に分けてるんだけど
こちらの説明はちょっとこの波論にはちょっと合わないんです
で ですから十七だから一から十七までやりますね
まあまあ こうこうこうやって瞬間瞬間は
心はそうやって瞬間瞬間十七倍変化するし
物質はそれでもそこであるんだと
そこで心の生の刹那と物質の生の刹那は同じだと
心の滅の刹那と物質の滅の刹那
また同じだと言ってるんですね
そうすると この波で書くとなんか
まあいきなりこう生まれて
こうやってこうやって亡くなるような感じになりますけどね
それ波にならないんですね
だからここは一番目の刹那で
ここで生まれてね まあここは一番目で
まあここ最後は十七番目でしょ
ここは十七番目で こっちが一番目です
で ここで二番目から十六番目までは住だと
まあ私は余計な説明だと思いますけどね
やっぱり波だからそちらにも
本当はそちらにも まあこういう風にあった方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
なんかあの ピカピカと光る電気とかいろいろありますね
そんな感じで光って消えて光って消えて感じるように考えてるんですけどね
でも光って消えてでもないんですよ
あれで目に見えないんだけど
ゆっくり光ってピークになって光って
またゆっくりと消えるんです
光ってる時間長いんだから光ってるように見えるだけ
もしかするとそういう風な感じかもしれませんね
まあだからとにかく住の時間はすごい長い
まあアビダンマ論によると
この物質の波はだいたい
まあこんな風な感じのものなんですね
だからこのピークここで終わって
この下行かないんだよね
また現れた それ だから物質的にそんな波存在するか
まあまあしないわけにもないんだけどね
激しいんですね この一定の柔らかい心のような
そんな感じの波ではないんですね
なんかちょっと まあそういうことで
まあなんでそういうことを言うかと
次にアビダンマで言いたがっていることの
この前からもう一応準備しておくんですよ
心の そういうのはこの横に書けないで
この後ろから前に書けるならば
この黒板にでもね 理解できると思います
そういうふうに書けませんから
で この存在だからね あるものが現れて
そのものが消える時のことを言ってるんだから
あるものが流れることを言ってるならば
黒板に書けますよ 波で
だから科学ではこういう流れると移動のことをやってるんですね
移動は考えてないんです
だからどうしても仏教の世界と科学の世界っていうのはもう正反対の世界にいるんです
だから仏教は堂々て堂々とあなた方は生というのは本当はもう生ではないんだ
あなた方はもう間違ってるというのはそうじゃなくて正しいというふうな
もう反対のことを言ってるんですね
どうしても物理学でも
やっぱりこういう移動ばっかり
この物理学 全部移動ばっかり考えてるんですね
移動 移動 移動 ですから移動するんだったら
移動する何か実体がなければいけませんし
それはもうずっといろんな形で移動しているんだ
それは物理学でもありますね
で 仏教で考える移動ではなくて
ある一箇所に何か物が現れたとしましょう
その現れたものが消えちゃうと
移動なしに 移動は不可能だそうです
そこは一つの刹那なんですね
ですから スクリーンに何か映像を映したことと
例えばスクリーンにスライドプロジェクターで映像
何かスライドを映しちゃうんだと
だから一つの絵を スライドをまあ 1 秒間映しちゃうと
1 秒止まったらすぐ次のスライドができちゃうと
いうと 我々にそれ黒板で書けますかね？横には書けないんですね
書く場合は横に書くんだけど
本当に起こった場合は横ではなくて縦に起きたんですね
ある一箇所で 1 秒間映像が映って
2 秒間  2 秒目は違う映像が映っていたんだと
じゃあ 3 秒間どんな映像を送って映ったんですかと描いてくださいって言ったら
私はもう横に描いてしまっちゃうんですね
起きたのは横ではなくて縦に起きたんですね
ですから それもスライドと同じく
例えばスライドで一 物質の映像をスクリーンに映った瞬間でまず映って
それから同じ光がどんどん入っちゃうと
あの映像がちょっと強烈になって
それから消えちゃうでしょう
そっとそれ消えちゃうんですね
だからこれは縦軸なの
縦の波なんですね 横波ではなくて
今我々知ってる縦波っていうのは何でしたっけ
で 何でしたっけ 地球の重力
引力っていうんですか
引力は縦波ですね ですから
私たちはどこにいても引っ張られる
遮断できない 他の何か光は遮断できますけどね
何か当たってそこから重力を遮断できますよ
遮断できないんですね
ですから 重力だけは何の物理の法則にも
一応もうそれを超えたいろいろやってますけどね
そこら辺やっちゃうと
まあもっともっと難しくなりますから
一応物質の現れる瞬間と消える瞬間は
心の現れる瞬間と消える瞬間と
時間的には同じ時間距離だということを言っています
で 次に九十六ページに移動します
で 九十六番ページのこの七番目の
五門という門ですね チャックドアラアティマハンターランマナリーティ
エーカチッタッカナアティータニワバフチッタッカナアティータニワティティッパッターネーヴァパンチャランマナニパンチャドアレーアパタムガッチャンティ
タスマヤディエーカチッタッカナアティータカムルーパランマナムチャックッサアパタムアガッチャティ
タトディッカットゥンバワンゲチャリテバワンガソータンウォッチンディットゥワタメワルーパランマナムアワッジャンタムパンチャドアラーワッジャナチッタムウッパジットゥワニルッジャティ
で説明では原問の極大所縁地
これからこの五門 五門というのは眼耳鼻舌身という五つの中に
どのように心のこの道がプロセスが現れるかと
眼耳鼻舌身の場合は極大
大 小 極小という四つのタイプがありますし
それはもう説明いたしました
極大というのは この眼耳鼻舌身に入る情報はほとんど入る場合なんですね
いわゆるもう四分の三以上情報が入ると
そこで眼耳鼻舌身に何が入るかというと
色声香味触という五つの情報が入るんですね
目には形 耳には音と 鼻には香りと
舌には味と 体には観測という五つの物質的なエネルギーが入ります
そこで物質的なエネルギーが入るんだから
触れちゃいますから これは存在している時のみ触れるんですね
例えば目に色が触れる時は色がいる時だけ触れる
いない時は触れない 当たり前のことなんですけど
だから色自体は無の状態で
いわゆる仏教では